one hundred years ago there were two
thousand varieties of peaches nearly two
thousand different varieties of plums in
almost 800 named varieties of apples
growing in the United States today only
a fraction of those remain and what is
left is threatened by industrialization
of Agriculture disease and climate
change those varieties that are
threatened include the blood cling a red
flesh peach brought by Spanish
missionaries to the Americas then
cultivated by Native Americans for
centuries an apricot that was brought by
Chinese immigrants who came to work on
the transcontinental railroad and
countless varieties of plums
that originated in the Middle East and
were then brought by Italian French and
German immigrants
none of these varieties are indigenous
in fact almost all of our fruit trees
were brought here including apples and
peaches and cherries so more than just
food embedded within these fruit is our
culture it's the people who cared for
and cultivated them who valued them so
much that they brought them here with
them as a connection to their home and
it's the way that they've passed them on
and shared them in many ways these fruit
are our story and I was fortunate enough
to learn about it through an artwork
that I created entitled the tree of 40
fruit the tree of 40 fruit is a single
tree that grows 40 different varieties
of stone fruit so that's peaches plums
apricots nectarines and cherries all
growing on one tree it's designed to be
a normal-looking tree throughout the
majority of the year until spring when
it blossoms in pink and white and then
in summer bears a multitude of different
fruit I began the project for purely
artistic reasons I wanted to change the
reality of the everyday and to be honest
create this startling moment when people
would see this tree
and you know blossom in all of these
different colors and bear all of these
different fruit I create the tree or 40
fruit through the process of grafting
I'll collect cuttings and winter store
them and then graph them on to the ends
of branches in spring in fact almost all
fruit trees are grafted because the seed
of a fruit tree is a genetic variant of
the parent so that when we find a
variety that we really like the way that
we propagated is by taking a cutting off
of one tree and putting it on to another
which is kind of crazy to think that
every single McIntosh Apple came from
one tree that's been grafted over and
over from generation to generation but
it also means that fruit trees can't be
preserved by sea I've known about
grafting as long as I can remember my
great grandfather made of living
grafting peach orchards in southeastern
Pennsylvania and although I never met
him anytime anyone would mention his
name they were quick to note that he
knew how to graft as if he had a magical
or mystical capability I decided on the
number 44 the tree of 40 fruit because
it's found throughout Western religion
is not the quantifiable dozen and not
the infinite but a number that's beyond
counting it's a bounty or a multitude
but the problem was is that when I
started I couldn't find 40 different
varieties of these fruit and this is
despite the fact that I live in New York
State which a century ago was one of the
leading producers of these fruit so as
they were tearing out research orchards
and old vintage orchards I would collect
branches off them and graph them onto
trees in my nursery so this is what the
tree or 40 fruit looked like when
they're first planted and this is what
they look like six years later this is
definitely not a sport of immediate
gratification it takes a year to know if
a graft is succeeded it takes two to
three years to know if it produces fruit
and it takes up to eight years to create
just one of the trees each of the
varieties grafted to the tree of 40
fruit has a slightly different form and
a slightly different color and I
realized that by creating a timeline of
when all these blossomed in relationship
to each other I can essentially shape or
design how the
reappears during spring and this is how
they appear during summer they produce
fruit from June through September 1st is
cherries then apricots Asian plums
nectarines and peaches and I think I
forgot one in there somewhere
although it's an artwork that exists
outside of the gallery as the project
continues it's been conservation by way
of the art world as I've been asked to
create these in different locations what
I'll do is I'll research varieties that
originated or were historically grown in
that area I'll source them locally and
graph them to the tree so that it
becomes an agricultural history of the
area where they're located and then the
project got picked up online which was
horrifying and humbling the horrifying
part was all of the tattoos that I saw
of images of the tree of 40 fruit which
I was like why would you do that to your
body and the humbling part was all of
the requests that I received from
pastors from rabbis and priests who
asked to use the tree as a central part
within their service and then it became
a meme and like the answer to that
question is I hope not like all good
memes this led to an interview on npr's
weekend edition and as a college
professor I thought I peaked like that
was the pinnacle of my career but you
never know who's listening to NPR and
several weeks after the NPR interview I
received an email from the Department of
Defense the Defense Advanced Research
Project administration invited me to
come talk about innovation and
creativity and it's a conversation that
quickly shifted to a discussion of food
security you see our national security
is dependent upon our food security now
that we've created these monocultures
that only grow a few varieties of each
crop if something happens to just one of
those varieties it can have a dramatic
impact upon our food supply and the key
to maintaining our food security is
preserving our biodiversity a hundred
years ago this was done by everybody
that had a garden or a small stand of
trees in their backyard and
varieties that were passed down through
their family these are plums from just
one tree of 40 fruit in one week in
August several years into the project I
was told that I had one of the largest
collection of these fruit in the eastern
United States which as an artist is
absolutely terrifying but in many ways I
didn't know what I had I discovered that
the majority of the varieties I had were
heirloom varieties so those be they were
grown before 1945 which is seen as the
dawn of the industrialization of
Agriculture several the varieties dated
back thousands and thousands of years
and finding out how rare they were I
became obsessed with trying to preserve
them and the vehicle for this became art
I would go into old vintage orchards
before they were torn out and I would
save the bowl or the trunk section that
possessed the original graft Union I
started doing pressings of flowers and
the leaves to create herbarium specimens
I started to sequence the DNA but
ultimately I set out to preserve the
story through these copperplate edgings
and letterpress descriptions to tell the
story of the gorge the forth peach which
took root between two buildings in New
York City someone walks by tastes it it
becomes a major commercial variety than
in the nineteenth century because it
tastes just that good then all but
vanishes because it doesn't ship well
and it doesn't conform to modern
agriculture but I realized that as a
story it needs to be told and in the
telling of that story it has to include
the experience of being able to touch to
smell and to taste those varieties so I
set out to creating orchard to make
these fruit available to the public and
had the aim of placing them in the
highest density of people that I could
possibly find naturally I started
looking for an acre of land in New York
City which in retrospect seemed like
rather ambitious and probably the reason
why nobody was returning my phone calls
or emails until eventually four years
later I heard back from Governors Island
so Governors Island is
former naval base that was given to the
city of New York in 2000 and it opened
up all of this land just a five-minute
ferry ride from New York and they
invited me to create a project that
we're calling the open orchard that'll
bring back fruit varieties that haven't
been grown in New York for over a
century currently in progress the open
orchard will be 50 multi grafted trees
that possess 200 heirloom and antique
fruit varieties so these are varieties
that originated or were historically
grown in the region varieties like the
early strawberry apple which originated
on 13th Street and 3rd Avenue since a
fruit tree can't be preserved by seed
the open orchard will act like a living
gene bank or an archive of these fruit
like the tree of 40 fruit it'll be
experiential it'll also be in symbolic
most importantly it's going to invite
people to participate in conservation
and to learn more about their food
through the tree of 40 fruit I've
received thousands and thousands of
emails from people asking basic
questions about how do you plant a tree
with less than 3% of the population
having any direct tie to agriculture the
open orchard is going to invite people
to come take part in public programming
and to take part in workshops to learn
how to graph to grow to prune and to
harvest a tree to take part in fresh
eating and blossom tours to work with
local chefs to learn how to use these
fruit and to recreate centuries-old
dishes that many of these varieties were
grown specifically for extending beyond
the physical sight of the orchard it'll
be a cookbook that compiles all of those
recipes it'll be a field guide that
talks about the characteristics and
trait of those fruit their origin in
their story growing up on a farm I
thought I understood agriculture and I
didn't want anything to do with it so I
became an artist but I have to admit
that it's something within my own DNA
and I don't think that I'm the only one
100 years ago we were all much more
closely tied to the culture the
cultivation and the story of our food
and we've been separated from that
the open orchard creates the opportunity
not just to reconnect to this unknown
past but a way for us to consider what
the future of our food could be thank
you
[Applause]